le mec qui me pique ma femme et il faut
que je sois sympa oui soit sympa il a
chopé une bactérie épouvantable quand il
faisait un safari au Kenya
c'est pas possible et c'est quoi la
suite du programme tu vas m'annoncer que
tu es enceinte
pardon je pense qu'il y a un pépin dans
votre histoire j'ai du mal à accepter
que un spectacle qui s'est censé me
remonter le moral ça me fait l'effet
inverse c'est je pense que vous n'êtes
pas du tout en train de vous rendre
compte monsieur mais en fait là ça se
fait pas du tout ce que vous faites en
fait vous écoutez ce que je raconte là
où je suis en train de pisser sur un
violon là il y a pas moyen que ça
continue vous vous voulez me torturer ou
quoi allez monsieur vous voulez qu'on
fasse quoi en fait exactement vous
voulez qu'on fasse quoi
on peut partir en sucette à n'importe
quel moment là cette histoire
c'est pas grave et si c'est grave vous
avez passé pour des guignols c'est pour
tout le monde merde
fais ça j'ai pas envie de trouver des
crever de quoi parle écoute-moi c'est
une sorte de là je couche avec toi
quoi attends je vais te promets si tu
nous sors de cette merde tu couches avec
moi comme tu veux pas te voir comme tu
veux neutralie ce mec quoi mais t'es pas
bien toi jamais rien à [__]
on peut partir en sucette à n'importe
quel moment là cette histoire d'accord
[Musique]